our mom is going tonight concerns breast
implants some are against them others
believe they're fine in rare cases and
many believe you should be able to get
them whenever the you want
sorry did I say breast implants I meant
abortions tonight's main topic concerns
abortions before before you change the
channel before you change the channel I
know this is a polarizing topic although
interestingly when the website Vox asked
people in the street for their opinions
the issue wasn't quite as binary as it's
usually presented if I had to pick I
would say that I'm pro-choice but
personally I'm more on a
somewhere in the middle I wouldn't but
arcade choose for other people I'm
pretty car pro-life I think when the
baby gets a heartbeat that should be the
cutoff point that's just my stance I'm
not the kind of guy like that I want
everyone to follow my stance okay well
not needing anyone to follow your stance
is a healthy attitude to abortion and
it's also a terrible attitude with which
to leave the Rockettes you do you
Bethany you do you girl you do you the
truth is people's opinions on abortion
make up a spectrum but most of us
believe it should be legal in at least a
few circumstances in fact only 19% of
Americans told Gallup they thought it
should be completely illegal and if you
are in that 90 percent you are frankly
excused from watching the rest of this
but but but do rejoin us at 11:29
because once I'm done talking about this
we'll all be watching a video featuring
a bucket of sloths and and I promise you
it is almost violently delightful but
but until that time the rest of us
really do need to talk about abortion
laws because wherever you are on this
spectrum whether you like me believe
that women should have the right to
choose or whether you believe abortion
should only be allowed in a few
circumstances then this story should
concern you and here is why since 2010
new state laws have contributed to the
closure of about 70 abortion clinics and
these four states are down to exactly
one abortion clinic each that's right
Mississippi now has four times as many
S's as it has abortion clinics and if
you're thinking how is that possible
well it's in no small part because the
key Supreme Court decision concerning
abortion is no longer Roe vs. Wade
it's the 1992 Planned Parenthood versus
Casey ruling that said states can create
restrictions as long as they don't place
an undue burden that places an a
substantial obstacle in the part of a
woman seeking an abortion meaning women
can be asked to jump through a few hoops
just not too many which might sound a
little less insulting if those weren't
also the rules for a dog agility course
and the vagueness of that ruling is
allowed states to introduce dozens of
what some have called trap laws or
targeted regulation of abortion
providers though their supporters to an
Erie degree all characterize them
somewhat differently this is really
about the issue of women's health we're
protecting women's health and safety we
are protecting women's health I just
wanted to reiterate that this is really
all about protecting the health and
safety of women yeah but when you're
that insistent about women's health it
starts to sound suspicious it's like
having a folder on your computer called
definitely not porn yeah you're not
fooling anyone you're asking more
questions than you're answering so so
let's take a look at what these laws
actually do for women's health
starting with Texas's hb2 which passed
in 2013 and had two key stipulations it
requires abortion clinics to meet the
same building standards as outpatient
surgical centers and requires their
doctors to have hospital admitting
privileges
okay now hospital admitting privileges
and high building standards sound great
until you realize what they actually
mean sort of how Moondance
sounds like a lovely night of romance
and whimsy but really means having sex
with Van Morrison and that's not what
you signed up for because the outpatient
surgical center requirements can be
difficult to fulfill as this Texas
clinic discovered explain again why it's
gonna be shut down because this isn't
wide enough yeah cuz right now the walls
that we have they're about three feet
wide and to being ASC it has to be eight
feet wide
now I'm not saying width isn't important
in fact in some circumstances it's far
more important than length is a thing
that I have hurt
penises I'm talking about penises but
that ain't thought requirement is wide
enough for two surgical Gurney's to pass
one another in a corridor which is just
not something that is likely to happen
at a small abortion clinic about 90% of
abortions occur in the first trimester
when they are generally non-surgical
procedures with no cutting and only mild
sedation they usually involve suction or
just taking medication neither of which
require a large surgical facility
you don't need an operating room to take
a pill which is a good thing because you
wouldn't want an entire surgical team
scrubbing in every time Larry King
needed a boner they'll get tired and and
as for Texas's law that doctors have
admitting privileges at a local hospital
a requirement 10 other states have also
passed that can shut a clinic down
because many hospitals for financial or
political reasons won't grant them to a
doctor who performs abortions and again
defenders of these laws will say they
have a simple purpose by requiring their
abortionists obtain admitting privileges
at local hospitals we are protecting
women's health yep but are you though
because it's worth noting both the AMA
and the American College of
Obstetricians and Gynaecologists have
argued there is simply no medical basis
for requiring local admitting privileges
which does make sense because hospitals
will see anyone they'll see you if
you've gotten an Elmo PEZ dispenser
stuck in your butt
they'll have questions for you but they
will see you they'll see you they'll
question you and later they may laugh at
you and while we are on the subject of
safety legal abortions have a mortality
rate of point zero zero zero seven three
percent that is nearly ten times less
than what one study found was the risk
for dying as the result of a colonoscopy
and let's agree by the way all of us
death by colonoscopy has to be one of
the worst ways to die right after having
your mother cachi masturbating and what
you're trying to pull your pants up you
fall and hit your head so your dad has
to carry your panceliss to the car to
take you to the hospital and the girl
next door you have a crush on tries to
help but she's laughing so hard at the
size of your penis that she closes the
door in your hand stopping your mother
who slams her foot on the gas dragon you
be
the car for several blocks while your
father yells your TV show is derivative
and you'll never escape the shadow of
John Stewart's
that's a general fear if admitting
privileges are so important for
continuity of care it is weird that you
don't need them in Texas to run a
birthing center even though one study
found that 12% of women admitted to
birthing centers wound up being
transferred to a hospital so Texas will
shut down an abortion clinic for having
walls too close together but if you want
to give birth in a tub surrounded by
mood lighting potpourri and the music of
Bon Iver no one will say anything other
than just take it down a notch and
proponents of these laws will point to a
few notorious cases like the clinic run
by Kermit Gosnell in Pennsylvania who
wound up being convicted of murder
although for the record his clinic had
not been inspected for 17 years which it
absolutely should have been they didn't
need new laws so much as they needed to
bother to enforce the ones they had
putting absurd new restrictions on all
clinics because of Kermit Gosnell is
like seeing that photo of a Taco Bell
employee licking the food and saying
okay all restaurants have to have
corridors that are eight feet wide
hold on that's gonna shut down most of
the restaurants in the country and
you've done nothing to address the root
problem here and some of these laws have
nothing whatsoever to do with clinic
safety like the ones that force doctors
like Willie Parker to actively spread
misinformation the state requires me to
cover some very basic information with
you first the state requires me to tell
you that if you're having an abortion
it's possible to having complications
there's a risk of bleeding there's a
risk of infection there's a risk of
damage to any of your organs but guess
what those are the exact same risk from
containing a pregnancy and going to turn
the final thing that I have to tell you
that I don't agree with but I have to
tell you in a way having an abortion can
increase your risk for breast cancer
there's not a shred of scientific
evidence to prove that they can require
me to tell you the first part but they
they can't stop me from giving you my
best medical opinion and that is that
there's no increased risk for breast
cancer from an abortion
it must be weird for a woman to witness
her medical professional forced to play
a game of good doctor bad doctor okay
time for your tetanus booster know those
cause autism well it's not a shred of
scientific evidence to prove that bad
doctor bad bad doctor in addition some
states have passed laws requiring
providers to show and describe an
ultrasound image whether a woman wants
to see that or not and when North
Carolina was defending such a law this
was how they attempted to soften that
the proposed law says if a woman wishes
not to see the ultrasound or hear the
fetal heartbeat she may cover her ears
and eyes and refuse to listen oh great
so North Carolina tried to give women
viewing ultrasounds the same option as
women trying to watch John Travolta's
performance in the new OJ Simpson show
oh my god oh my god what is he doing Oh
does he think Robert Shapiro was a sad
clown in Abbas Lerman movie I didn't
want to watch this why are you making me
and some other clinics enter into a
bureaucratic war as a result of these
laws take this clinic in Alabama it was
shut down after not being able to meet
the new building codes Alabama had
forced upon it but instead of giving up
the owner cashed in his retirement
savings to open a new facility that
complied completely with the law and
that is when Alabama started targeting
him directly I'm spared close to a
million dollars to meet all of their
requirements and you think you're done
and what are they trying to do they're
trying to pass another bill that said I
can't be in 2,000 feet of the school
they're treating me the patients the
physicians as sex offenders well they're
treating someone like a sex offender
when he clearly isn't one it's a move
that's now commonly known as I reverse
Cosby look
and look if you are thinking if you're
thinking the job look when a clinic
closes can't women just travel further
you should know there are now mandatory
waiting periods in 27 states some up to
72 hours between an initial consult and
an abortion so women can be forced to
either take multiple trips or plan the
shittiest three-day weekend imaginable
and if that's not possible they can end
up making desperate decisions listen to
one clinic administrator describe a call
from a patient's I told her you can come
to San Antonio we can help you here and
she said I can't I have I don't have the
means there's no way I can get to San
Antonio so what if I tell you what I
have in my kitchen cabinet and you tell
me what I could do I'll tell you what I
have in my kitchen cabinet and you can
tell me what I can do when your state's
abortion laws are forcing people into
the most depressing Quickfire challenge
in Top Chef history I think it's safe to
say they've gone too far because
here is the thing abortion cannot just
be theoretically legal it has to be
literally accessible and remember every
single one of us watching this right now
every every single one of us watching
right now agrees that it should be legal
at the very least in a few extreme
circumstances say hypothetically a young
girl has been the victim of sexual
assault well thanks to these laws this
hypothetical girl might have to travel a
long distance because there were no
clinics close to her and again thanks to
these laws the girl might be approaching
the point where her state won't let her
get the procedure at all well sadly none
of that is hypothetical and I'll let the
Texas clinic director tell you the rest
in order to see her I need to put her to
sleep and in order to do that I need a
nurse anesthetist and because this crazy
law it is impossible to find people to
work for us she's 13 years old and she
is a victim of rape and she drove four
hours from McAllen to San Antonio and we
had to turn her way and there was
nothing I could do to save her and so
now if she has a procedure that if is
huge
shoved all the way to New Mexico and pay
$5,000 and get there
and spend three days you don't never
happen we know about and at that point
we have sentenced a child to motherhood
now that specific provider whole woman's
health is actually at the center of a
Supreme Court case that will be heard
next month if it's a 4-4 tie the Texas
laws stand so the best hope is that
Justice Kennedy seen here in dog form
straightening his tie will see Texas
regulation as an undue burden this whole
situation is basically in his paws now
meanwhile Florida is drafting similar
trap laws and the law in Alabama that
would close that one clinic near a
school will be introduced to committee
later this week and if all this has made
you sad or angry then you should really
keep an eye on these laws and if you
don't have a problem with the current
situation then well it is 11:29 welcome
back
thanks for rejoining us 19% a quick
question what the is wrong with you
but but nothing up top know what putting
our size
I made I made a promise I promise
everyone sloths in a bucket and that is
what you are going to see although if
you are in that 19% I'm going to have to
insist that you cover your ears and eyes
and refuse to listen for everyone else
it is sloth apart you are very welcome
now I know I know this story has not
been the ideal way for anyone to go to
sleep on a Sunday night but but we
thought that this was something you
should really know about and the only
way that I can make it right is to give
you the absolutely ideal way to go to
sleep an actual sloth in a nightcap this
is thank you so much for watching the
show
with knives
Oh